bonsoir voici les titres de ce journal
messieurs jean pierre chevènement est
sorti du coma c'est ce que vient
d'annoncer l'hôpital du val de grâce aux
etats-unis le procureur star on est aux
parlementaires américains son rapport
sur la fir levinsky menaçant ainsi le
mandat de bill clinton
en russie le président helsinn choisi
son actuelle ministre affaires
étrangères viesly primakov comme
candidat premier ministre il est assuré
de l'investiture demain le rapport
parlementaire sur la corse salué à
l'unanimité reportage sur la justice
dans l'île notre invité jean glavany le
président de la commission parlementaire
à deauville au festival de cinéma
américain projection du film metteur en
scène soderbergh hors d'atteinte avec
george clooney qui sera notre invité en
direct dans quelques minutes
le ministre de l'intérieur monsieur jean
pierre chevènement est sorti du coma il
a pu reconnaître ses proches c'est le
communiqué de l'hôpital du val-de-grâce
diffusé en fin d'après-midi le ministre
avait été hospitalisée le 1er septembre
pour une opération de la vésicule
biliaire il était dans le coma après un
arrêt cardiaque provoquée par une
allergie aux curares lors d'une
anesthésie
c'est le médecin général du val de grâce
monsieur hifti denek qui a rendu public
ce bulletin de santé encourageant après
la diminution de la sédation
monsieur jean pierre chevènement est
sorti du coma et a pu reconnaître ses
proches il existe un mieux certains en
ce qui concerne les différentes lésions
viscéral mais l'assistance respiratoire
et la suppléance rénale par dialyse sont
encore nécessaires par ailleurs
l'origine allergique aux curares du choc
anesthésique a été démontré par les
tests de laboratoire
jean daniel flaysakier quelle est la
signification de ce communiqué
concrètement ça veut dire une chose très
importante le fait qu'il ait pu
reconnaître ses proches ça veut dire que
les eaux des zones aussi différentes et
éloignés dans le cerveau que les zones
de la vision de la mémoire reason qui
associe vision et mémoires sont intactes
or comme je voulais dit ces zones sont à
différents endroits aussi bien à gauche
qu'à droite dans le cerveau qu en
arrière ça prouve que même avant qu en
effet le scanner on sait qu'un certain
nombre de parties vitales du cerveau
n'ont pas été touchés ça c'est très
important
et quand l'appareil de respiratoires
sera enlevé on pourra juger à la qualité
de la parole de l'élocution et du choix
des mots là encore l'importance
éventuelle de lésions de la dans les
zones de la parole mais s'il peut parler
normalement ça sera encore un point très
important qui ont encore gagné les
médecins avec constat également de
réaction des membres inférieurs oui il
semble d'après certaines informations
que nous avons pu obtenir que la montre
ce qu'on appelle la motricité c'est à
dire les mouvements et des muscles des
jambes et des bras soit en partie pour
l'instant pourtant qu'on puisse savoir
conserver il faut être extrêmement
prudent avant l'évaluation définitive
mais apparemment il ya aussi des signes
très encourageants alors il hier
l'hôpital du val-de-grâce confirmait que
le ministre avait subi des visites
préopératoire et on a confirmé aussi
aujourd'hui qu'ils avaient bien fait une
allergie au curragh on sait sur des
tests qui ont été faits à posteriori
c'est à dire après l'accident que c'est
bien le produit utilisé qui était à
l'origine du choc
on aurait pu alors certains disent pour
qu'on ne fait pas ces tests a priori en
fait aujourd'hui c'était son fondation
absolument pas fiable et ne veulent rien
dire il ya des gens qui vont avoir un
test au curragh négatif et qui vont
faire un gros accidents d'allergie et
des gens qui vont à une petite réaction
sur la peau et qui vont passer
l'anesthésiste j'allais dire comme une
fleur
ces tests a priori n'ont aucun intérêt
en revanche maintenant on sait que le
ministre est allergique aux curares si
on devait un jour leur père et on
prendrait des noms de précaution bien
sûr vis-à-vis de ses produits alors
prochaine étape et durée éventuelle
cession
étape le sevrer de sa machine qui lui
sert à respirer ça va être un petit peu
long autre étape débranché au rein
artificiel qui suppléait son rein
défaillant pour le reste malheureusement
personne ne peut faire de pronostic
il faut voir ce qui est quelle est
l'étendue des lésions c'est le scanner
et l'imagerie par résonance magnétique
qui donneront les diagnostics et puis on
transall long processus de rééducation
mais personne n'a encore ne peut faire
de pronostic
et spéculer sur les suites éventuelles
merci à washington ce sont maintenant
les parlementaires américains qui
doivent prendre le relais du procureur
kenneth starr celui ci leur a remis son
rapport enfermé dans quelques 36 cartons
sur la sphère levinsky plus exactement
sur l'effet autorisant le procureur a
accusé de parjure d'abus de pouvoir de
subornation de témoin le président des
états unis bill clinton
reportage de notre correspondant à
washington philippe gassot à peine les
cartons remplis de confidences de
témoignages et autres délation était il
a porté presque par surprise au congrès
dans deux vannes usb qu'on y voyait là
encore une finesse un épisode de la
stratégie du procureur kenneth starr il
s'agissait pour lui de prendre la
présidence de vitesse à la maison
blanche bien déserté par les temps qui
courent on tentait d'allumer un timmy
contre-feu qui n'a jusqu'à présent
convaincu personne
il n'ya dans tout cela on qu'un élément
susceptible de conclure à une
destitution
ce qui trouble aujourd'hui l'amérique
c'est comme le dit la pub ce qu'il y a
dans la boîte et il y a les cassettes
vidéo des dépositions du président
les bandes pirates de linda trie les
dépositions des témoins devant le grand
jury tout y y
sans oublier les rapports d'expertisé
pour les tâches en tout genre si le
procureur a versé le contenu du rapport
au congrès c'est qu'il est bien certain
qu'il y aura sanction le président
risque impeachment la procédure de
destitution au congrès si de nombreux
républicains avaient rêvé de faire
toucher les épaules à bill clinton
ils vont manier à présent le rapport
avec doigté l'opinion veille
nous voulons dépenser tout cela sans
esprit partisan cela veut dire démocrate
et république
ensemble la commission judiciaire
réclament des délais pour prendre
connaissance du rapport
ensuite la chambre pourrait être saisie
et s'il le faut le sénat jugera en ce
moment la commission des règlements est
réuni et a déjà décidé de mettre une
partie du rapport sur internet
le grand déballage est annoncé le
président dans sa cascade d'excusés à
répétition est un homme seul que l'on
évite même dans certains me file
démocrates philippe gassot washington ce
soir je suppose qu'on s'interroge sur ce
qui va se passer maintenant concrètement
au congrès notamment et bien en ce
moment le rapport de kenneth starr en ce
moment le rapport de kenneth starr est
entre les mains de la commission
judiciaire du parlement
et si cette commission statue sur le
fait que bill clinton a commis des
erreurs incompatible avec son mandat
et bien cette commission va transmettre
le dossier aux parlementaires et s'il
arrive à la même conclusion
eh bien ces parlementaires vont
transmettre le dossier au sénat qui lui
sera tenue de juger le président avec la
majorité des deux tiers
alors il peut s'agir du fameuse
impeachment on parle beaucoup maintenant
c'est à dire de ne plus donner les
moyens au président d'exercer son mandat
ou alors il peut s'agir simplement d'un
blâme alors quels sont les délais
envisageable eh bien écoutez ça peut
être très court quelques jours quelques
semaines
si on veut statuer sur le sort du
président avant les élections de
novembre prochain qui doivent renouveler
partiellement le parlement ou alors ce
sera non pas une question de semaines
mais plutôt une question de mois merci
philippe en russie le président eltsine
céder aux exigences des députés de la
douma chambre basse du parlement russe
il a renoncé à présenter une troisième
fois la candidature de monsieur victor
tchernomirdine ce sera donc l'actuel me
lisent affaires étrangères monsieur
evgueni primakov qui demain devant les
députés sollicitera leurs suffrages et
l'on sait dès ce soir qu'il les
obtiendra en majorité puisque les
communistes et leurs alliés ont annoncé
qu'ils avaient décidé de voter pour lui
voici qui est monsieur evgueni primakov
le futur premier ministre de russie
portrait dressé par j
rabin efron brisset primakov lentilles
américain viscéral est devenu l'un des
amis proches de madeleine albright chefs
de la diplomatie des états unis
officiellement son adversaire ils ne se
feront pas de cadeaux mais peut-être
parce qu'entre il n'y a jamais eu
d'interprète
elle parle russe il parle anglais
parfois leur échappe
un petit geste de tendresse mais il est
aussi l'ami des iraniens et des irakiens
qui donne des cauchemars aux américains
ils parlent l'arabe il a longtemps été
le patron de l'institut d'orient à
moscou bref hier guinea primakov c'est
l'homme qui connaît la terre entière
c'est aussi l'homme qui ne se met jamais
au premier rang alors que depuis des
décennies il joue dans l'ombre des
premiers rôles où tout dernier congrès
du parti communiste soviétique primakov
était assis derrière boris eltsine
alors qu'en réalité dans la hiérarchie
d'époque il était au dessus de lui
rybakov a vécu aux premières loges les
grandes heures des 30 dernières années
et les moins grandes
comme ce 1er mai 1990 où la foule avait
conspué gorbatchev sur la place rouge
il a survécu à tous les régimes à
l'effondrement de l'union soviétique
passant des missions secrètes à la
direction des services secrets puis à
celle de la diplomatie russe boris et
s'il a choisi après plus de deux
semaines de tourmente parce qu'il n'est
pas candidat à sa succession et surtout
parce qu'il sera préservé un minimum de
dignité aux arts boris dans une fin de
règne qui s'annonce cahotique gide rabin
je suppose que ce soit est un petit peu
de soulagement dans l'ambiance politique
au moins soulagement mais provisoire
avec l'autre parce que avant-hier soir
c'est un grand vide politique à moscou
il n'y avait plus de candidats capables
à la fois d'obtenir l'investiture de la
douma et d'affronter la crise économique
hier gainey primakov ne voulait pas de
ce fauteuil de chef de gouvernement et
avant de se dévouer il a posé ses
conditions c'est à dire investiture
immédiate dès demain et carte blanche
donnée par la douma et par le kremlin
mais alors que va t'il j'allais dire
même que petit faire est-ce que c'est
l'homme idoine pour diriger la russie
mais vous savez je veux ni prime un
coffre a soutenu une thèse de doctorat
en sciences économiques mais en 1954
sous khrouchtchev
à cette époque là à moscou qui était
encore la capitale de l'union soviétique
ont enseigné précisément pas d'économie
de marché
bien sûr monsieur primakov est célèbre
pour la vivacité de son intelligence et
bien évidemment il a pris la mesure des
enjeux et des défis à relever à relever
et c'est précisément pour cela qu'il a
hésité longtemps il sait que cette
émission à très haut risque que sa marge
de manoeuvre après quinze jours de crise
extrêmement étroite
merci gym le premier ministre monsieur
lionel jospin en visite en finlande a
fait part d'une prudence teintée
d'optimisme ce site
après la nomination par boris elstine de
monsieur primakov ses hôtes finlandais
notamment le premier ministre monsieur
lipponen compartiment attentif à ce qui
se passe à moscou les russes sont leurs
voisins et les finlandais membres de
l'union européenne s'inquiète des
répercussions économiques et sociales à
leurs frontières en espagne ce soir deux
anciens ministres socialistes du
gouvernement de monsieur felipe gonzalez
sont entrés en prison l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur espagnol et son adjoint
avaient été condamnés à dix en détention
dans le procès des groupes
antiterroristes de libération le gall
qui opérait également en france les
socialistes espagnols font bloc autour
des deux condamnés et dénonce une
manoeuvre de l'actuel gouvernement de
monsieur asnar ce soir ils se sont
déplacés jusqu'à la prison de
guadalajara pour accompagner les deux
anciens ministres commentaire maryse
burgot ils sont plusieurs centaines ce
soir devant les portes de la prison de
guadalajara l'état major du parti
socialiste espagnol au complet et des
dizaines de sympathisants
tous venus soutenir ces deux hommes josé
barrionuevo ex ministre de l'intérieur
et son adjoint raphaël verra deux ex
ministres du gouvernement espagnol que
l'on voit ici rejoindre la prison
soutenu par les leurs parmi ses
sympathisants il ya aussi felipe
gonzalez ancien chef du gouvernement
leur condamnation date de juillet
dernier lors d'un procès désormais
historique
il était condamné à 10 ans de prison
accusé comme dix autres inculpés d'avoir
organisé ce qu'on a appelé la sale
guerre contre les séparatistes basques
une sale guerre qui débute dans les
années 80 pour lutter contre le
terrorisme basque une sorte de police
parallèle est à l'époque créé légal un
groupe anti terroriste qui va
revendiquer 28 assassinat le
gouvernement espagnol est à l'époque
dirigée par felipe gonzalez soupçonné
d'être à l'origine de la création de
seagal il n'y est est finalement écarté
lors de l'instruction de la sphère
barrionuevo et son adjoint eux n'ont pas
échappé aux juges et à la prison et 7
aujourd'hui tous les socialistes qui
crie au complot politique
un complot distille ourbih par la droite
aujourd'hui au pouvoir en espagne en
france jour de rentrée scolaire dans les
lycées le ministre claude allègre a
choisi volontairement de se rendre dans
un lycée professionnel en insistant sur
la réussite de cet enseignement qui
débouche sur de vrais emplois
il y aura même une prochaine campagne
nationale de promotion densément
professionnels en attendant je vous
propose une visite à tour dans un lycée
préparant les élèves aux métiers du
graphisme reportage nathalie moison
nathalie gallet une rentrée au lycée
sous le regard des parents
entre le bep l'an dernier le bac
professionnel en deux ans il y à une
marche à franchir mais elle m'inquiète
que les parents damien lui a trouvé sa
voie depuis qu'il a quitté
l'enseignement général
c'est un stage en troisième j'ai
découvert l'imprimerie qui va ça va plus
j'ai lycéens en jette
pendant ces deux années de formation
d'amiens devra passer 14 semaines en
entreprise des singes qui seront un
tremplin pour son entrée dans la vie
active
nous avons aussi des offres d'emploi qui
nous arrivent par les professionnels et
cette année en impression en particulier
nous avions probablement deux fois plus
d'offres d'emploi que d'élèves sortant
avant d'en arriver là dès l'entrée au
bep ici en hôtellerie les plus jeunes
sont avertis
je voudrais vous dire tout de suite on
entre et que vous avez fini de prendre
et grandes vacances depuis toujours
christel veut être cuisinière mais ne
lui dites surtout pas qu'elle embrasse
mes études courtes
si les diplômes il voulait rester
le bac professionnel puis pourquoi pas
des mentions et donc elle a pris
vraiment la voie qui lui plaît le plus
et puis comme c'est fort allez on va
dire propre une intellectuelle préférées
annuel ici je pense qu'elle aura ce
qu'elle veut et les cours sont plutôt
axés sur le travail manuel sur
l'apprentissage du métro une motivation
et une fierté qu'on essaie de recréer
ici pour que la voie professionnelle ne
soit plus pour certains élèves une
orientation par l'échec
alors pas de grève ou presque
aujourd'hui pour cette rentrée dans les
lycées presque puisque noter cependant
que 50 % des enseignants des classes
préparatoires aux grandes écoles ne sont
pas venus ce matin manifestant ainsi
leur opposition à la baisse des taux de
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
le ministre claude allègre a obtenu un
répit dans la contestation syndicale le
préavis de grève a été reporté au 18
septembre prochain celui du snes fsu
et cette rentrée scolaire 98 était
jusqu'à présent plutôt calme le dialogue
semble s'imposer
reportage jean bernard schmidt ménard
dit ça c'est un grand le ton change
entre claude allègre et les syndics
quelque chose il ya un an
le ministre de l'éducation fustigé le
mammouth et dénoncé le corporatisme des
enseignants
aujourd'hui les propos sont nettement
plus mesuré toutes les personnes qui
veulent parler vous l'avez vu avec tout
le monde
son je suis toujours disponible la
raison de cet appel au dialogue lancé il
ya dix jours la menace d'une grève
brandie par le snes principal syndicat
du second degré autre raison plus
officieuse claude allègre se serait fait
gentiment rappelé à l'ordre par ses amis
socialistes
soucieux de préserver de bons rapports
avec les enseignants résultat retour à
la concertation
après trois rencontres au ministère le
snes décide de reporter la grève
plusieurs dossiers sensibles ont évolué
le salaire de certains professeurs sera
revalorisé la situation des maîtres
auxiliaires les plus anciens devrait se
régler dès cette année enfin le snes a
accepté de participer à des discussions
sur la réforme des lycées
en revanche certains dossiers demeurent
très problématique c'est le cas de la
rémunération des heures supplémentaires
autre point de blocage les mutations des
professeurs le snes attend plus de
garanties mais au moins on discute
les conditions d'un dialogue sont
établis et maintenant c'est le contenu
qui va compter et s'il veut faire preuve
de bonne volonté le snes n'entend pas
pour autant relâcher la pression
deux appels à la grève sont lancés pour
les 18 et 24 septembre prochains
démonstrations spectaculaires des
éleveurs de porcs c'était à segré dans
le maine et loire ils ont envahi un
supermarché ils ont vidé les rayons et
ensuite ils ont toutes offert aux
clients les éleveurs de porcs volts
obtenir des aides de l'état de la
communauté européenne pour compenser la
baisse des cours de la viande de porc ce
matin les cotations de cette viande
n'ont pu avoir lieu les prix étaient
trop bas 5 francs 84 de mainmise
agriculture doit annoncer des mesures
d'accompagnement mais cette nuit des
producteurs de porcs du finistère doit
se rassembler à quimper à l'assemblée
nationale tous les groupes politiques
représentés ont salué le travail de la
commission d' enquête parlementaire sur
l'utilisation des fonds publics en corse
le rapport de cette commission a été
remis hier à monsieur jospin
il souligne la co responsabilité de
l'état dont les dents les maux dont
souffrent lille corse
parmi les dysfonctionnements des
institutions ceux de la justice ce matin
nous sommes rendus au palais de justice
de bastia
reportage coq sans père patrick desmulie
dans quelques jours le procureur général
va inaugurer dans ses locaux le premier
pool économique et financier en france
les travaux s'achèvent ici vont bientôt
travailler des magistrats spécialiste
des affaires financières à l'abri de
quelques portes blindées
mais aujourd'hui au tribunal de bastia
on parlait surtout du rapport de la
commission denquête très critique
vis-à-vis du fonctionnement de la
justice dans l'île il y à un
dysfonctionnement général au niveau
l'appareil d'état il ya eu de nombreuses
hésitations en matière
de politique face aux problèmes de la
corse
mais je ne voudrais pas que d'une
manière ou d'une autre aujourd'hui la
justice soit montré du doigt où
apparaissent comme étant dans ce
contexte le bouc émissaire le rapport
évoque aussi la responsabilité de paris
parfois avait des politiques qui
changeait tous les six mois
ce que vous partagez cette analyse je
pense que à l'examen des archives du
parquet général
par exemple cette réalité est évidente
du côté du président du tribunal ou même
tonalité
d'autres vols à la confirmation de ce
que nous avons dénoncé dans vous ne
pourront pas dire que c'est sévère
puisqu'on l'avions dénoncé aujourd'hui
les choses changent un peu aujourd'hui
effectivement les choses changent il ya
une volonté de nous ne devons laisser
travailler donc vous travaillez dur oui
seul problème le manque de civisme de la
population
il y a trois semaines le meurtre d'un
jeune nationaliste devant 40 personnes à
ce jour les magistrats n'ont reçu aucun
témoignage ce jean glavany bonsoir
d'asseoir une à limiter ce formidable
mais je vais dire qu'attendiez-vous
pourquoi est-ce que vous avez pas fait
ce travail parlementaire plutôt on peut
dire d'une certaine heure on l'avait
commencé plus tôt puisque sous la
précédente législature il y avait une
mission d'information parlementaire qui
s'étaient réunis
elle avait interrompu ses travaux à
cause de la dissolution on a repris
notre travail sous cette législature
sous forme d'une commission d' enquête
parlementaire dans le secret en
responsabilité je crois que c'est une
trente parlementaires issus de tous les
horizons politiques avec nos divergences
nos différences on a débattu entre nous
nos fonds on a fait preuve de
suffisamment de responsabilité pour se
retrouver sur l'essentiel c'est à dire
la volonté de de dire la vérité parce
que nos concitoyens de la france toute
entière est dans l'île en partie aux
besoins de la vérité et puis d'essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passait ça
travaille comment une commission
parlementaire salaire vous avez débarqué
un petit peu partout y compris l'ipad
justice à travail de trois manières
d'abord nous auditionnons beaucoup de
gens plusieurs fois par semaine à
l'assemblée nationale dans le secret
sans dire qu'ils nous auditionnons
ensuite nous avons exigé du des
ministères qui ont joué le jeu
remarquablement qu'ils nous ouvrent tous
leurs dossiers de façon à ce que nous
ayons accès à tous les rapports
d'inspection tous les rapports des corps
de contrôle des années des liens avaient
beaucoup effectivement et on s'est
aperçu que à peu près tous savaient
d'une manière éparpillée mais nous avons
maintenant l'occasion de donner une vue
d'ensemble et puis enfin effectivement
nous sommes allés sur l'île à de
nombreuses reprises sans prévenir les
avoirs le magistrat ils ont accepté de
vous parler tranquillement ils se sont
même on nous sommes arrivé un jour au
palais de justice de bastia il en
prévenant la veille et on se fait tant
les rencontres et il y en a même sur
venue d'ajaccio pour nous rencontrer et
vous voulez nous parler s'il y avait une
incroyable une soif de communiquer de
dire les choses qui étaient très
frappante a partout où nous sommes allés
et vous en parler individuellement ils
ont refusé de nous voir collectivement
les magistrats voulaient nous voir un
par un alors vous dites ça servait alors
si on savait autant de choses pourquoi
et la gauche et la droite n'ont jamais
vraiment bougé je crois que c'est une
des choses que nous mettons en évidence
dans ce rapport il ya une
coresponsabilité ne faut pas hors de
question d'accuser la communauté corse
et les corses en général ça serait
injuste et 1
et indistincte il faut savoir qu'en
corse il y a une majorité de gens grande
majorité de gens qui sont les victimes
de la situation population corse est une
petite minorité qui sont les coupables
il faut pas faire d'amalgamé mais je
crois que c'est une des choses claires
que le rapport dit c'est fait la
distinction entre la majorité et la
minorité
et puis à une responsabilité de l'état
nous nous essayons de la définir et de
l'expliquer je crois que au fond si on
devait la résumer c'est que tous les
gouvernements de bonne foi oui je ne
fais pas de procès d'intention de bonne
foi ont cru à chaque fois qu'ils
arrivaient au pouvoir que il pourrait
acquérir acheter la paix civile en
faisant de nouvelles avancées
institutionnelles en effaçant des dettes
en temps de nouvelles dérogations
fiscales d amnistie en changeant un
statut un jean statut bref en pensant
qu'ils allaient acquérir la paix civile
avec ces dérogations et ces nouvelles
mesures est en fait à chaque fois loin
d'acquérir la paix civile est en venu
mais le problème pourquoi parce que ceux
qui revendiquaient se trouvait toujours
dans la situation de revendiquer un peu
plus ce m'étais déjà d'un coup d'après
dans la surenchère
et puis elle située en corse était un
peu découragé depuis et leurs impôts
puisqu'ils se disait après tout va y
avoir la nouvelle amnistie fiscale
depuis y et leurs dettes puisque l'effet
des dettes vont être effacées etc et les
administrations et elle même décourager
on imagine des juges ou des policiers
qui se disait pourquoi coffret tel ou
tel individu s'il veut être amnistié
dans six mois et donc c'était un
engrenage infernal
ça partait de la bonne foi des
gouvernements mais ça se retrouvait dans
un engrenage en fait qu'est-ce qui peut
nous faire croire que après ce rapport
ça va changer et et inscrira des suites
est ce que vous avez continué à
contrôler qu'est ce qui va se passer
réellement il ya trois raisons de croire
cela
mais il faut être vigilant la première
c'est que je ne me semble que à part
tellement que ce nous faisons ce constat
sans fard qui est un peu brutal à je le
reconnais mais qui est en même temps
cette exigence de vérité nous pouvons
provoquer une prise de conscience dans
l'île pour réveiller cette conscience
citoyenne et qu'elles deviennent actives
et qu'elle exige c'est suite justement
les signes nous font penser que c'est
possible la deuxième chose positive
c'est que au fond nous avons décidé d
affecter proposition de demander une
suite de mettre en place un comité de
suivi à l'assemblée j'en ai parlé au
président fabius et lionel jospin est
d'accord pour cela vous a baissé de 2,2
d'institutionnaliser ce suivi et
parlementaires de l'opposition syrienne
a entendu
et puis la troisième raison c'est que
d'une certaine mère ça a commencé hier
que le gouvernement
on a commencé ce travail et nous nous
sommes retrouvés en phase avec lui les
travaux que nous avons faits qui
réclament le rétablissement de l'état de
droit dans l'île au fond c'est ce que le
gouvernement fait depuis un an
il va pouvoir s'appuyer sur sur ce
rapport et nous nous allons pouvoir
appuyer son action
ça fait plaisir quand fait la pratique
d'être saluée par tout le monde dont je
suppose c'est assez rare mais enfin
c'est le sujet est assez grave comme ça
aussi
merci jean glavany l'arrestation à
cannes dovizioso gély âgé de 79 ans il a
même été hospitalisé après son
arrestation cet homme fut l'ancien grand
maître de la loge maçonnique p2 en
italie fut mêlé à de nombreuses
histoires mafieuses et financière dont
le krach de la banque ambrosiano on
soupçonne également la loge p2 d'être
lié à l'extrême droite qui se livrait
dans les années 70 et 80 à des actes
terroristes
la bourse de paris a enregistré sa plus
forte baisse depuis octobre 92 elle a
perdu près de 4 60% aujourd'hui c'est
les investisseurs sont inquiets de la
chute de la bourse américaine à wall
street à mi-journée une forte baisse
également nouvelle campagne anti tabac à
partir d'aujourd'hui en france cette vie
surtout à aider ceux qui souhaitent
arrêter de fumer plusieurs dispositions
sont prises pour encourager les fumeurs
à devenir moins dépendants reporte à
gilles marine est rémi poissonnier
avant-hier j'ai arrêté de fumer hier
j'ai arrêté d'arrêter de fumer
aujourd'hui
cette année la campagne de publicité
n'emprunte pas les voies détournées
arrêter de fumer
c'est la galère et les spots télévisés
ne cache rien des difficultés qui
attendent les 39 % de fumeurs désireux
d'en finir avec le tabac pour les
accompagner une nouveauté tabac info
service une ligne de téléphone
expérimenté depuis quelques jours auprès
des usagers du métro est aujourd'hui
accessible à tous
au bout du fil des spécialistes
estimations de la dépendance et surtout
orientation il repartira avec l'adresse
d'un médecin certains pourront s'arrêter
avec de simples conseils et de la
volonté
mais pour environ un tiers des fumeurs
dont l'organisme plus propices que
d'autres à la dépendance
il faudra un accompagnement nous sommes
dans une consultation de tabacologie
suzy à 35 ans elle attend son troisième
enfant
elle n'a jusque là jamais pu s'arrêter
de fumer ou des fumées avec un patch je
le sais je peux pas rester deux heures
dans une salle de cinéma sans fumée si
je fais un voyage en avion ongles en
classe dans des avions il n'y a pas de
section fumeur je suis pratiquement que
je prendre un tranquillisant je ne peux
pas je ne sais que je ne peux pas y
arriver sans l'aide de ce service
analyse tests et en cas de difficulté
modification du dosage du patch le suivi
demande beaucoup de temps sont des
consultations qui sont longues
surtout la première qui fait analyser le
tabagisme les antécédents et cetera de
fumeurs et l'histoire du fumeur et le
degré de motivation etc
il ya tout un tas de questionnaires la
tabacologie est une discipline
universitaire récente il n'existe qu'une
centaine de consultations en france
alors que la cigarette tue 60 mille
personnes par an et que les études les
plus récentes révèlent qu'à l'âge de 19
ans un jeune sur deux est un fumeur la
revue scientifique américaine human
reproduction a publié hier les travaux
de chercheurs en génétique qui affirme
qu'il est désormais possible de choisir
le sexe de son enfant leur méthode
permet de sélectionner les
spermatozoïdes les plus aptes à produire
soit un garçon soit une fille mais cette
méthode ne peut être généralisé et pose
surtout des problèmes éthiques
explication jean daniel flaysakier ce
laboratoire pense avoir mis au point la
méthode qui garanti dès la conception
le sexe de l'enfant à venir dans la
nature ce sont les spermatozoïdes du
père qui décide du sexe en fonction du
patrimoine génétique qu'ils hébergent
si le spermatozoïde est porteur d'un
chromosome x ce sera une fille si c'est
un chromosome y
ce sera un garçon les chercheurs ont
réussi à isoler les spermatozoïdes
géniteur de filles
ils ont ainsi obtenu 13 filles sur 14
naissances mais il a fallu avoir recours
à l'insémination artificielle et 85 %
des tentatives de grossesse ont échoué
cette méthode lourdes et onéreuses pour
aussi une grave question morale car
elles risquent de rompre l'équilibré
naturel entre filles et garçons
je pense que cette méthode qui peut
avoir un réel intérêt médical
lorsqu'il s'agit d'un acte médical de
prévenir un risque réel de récidive de
maladies génétiques
lorsqu'on est dans le contexte d'une
demande de convenance personnelle parce
qu'on a envie d'avoir un garçon ou parce
qu'on a envie d'avoir une fille alors
c'est totalement inacceptable et or de
l'esprit de la loi
bientôt on pourra choisir le sexe de son
enfant et que paul tarlé la couleur des
yeux ou des cheveux ça c'est
inacceptable
en france la loi bioéthique interdit de
telles pratiques les shoes et les roses
ont encore de beaux jours devant eux
sport football 5e journée du championnat
de france de première division avec une
curiosité puisque dans les rangs de l'as
nancy lorraine sera aligné pour la
première fois en france un joueur
chinois il s'appelle jim young lee et il
effectuera ses débuts au stade marcel
picot face au paris saint germain ce
soir reportage laurent frédéric bollée
et michel anglade à l'est du nouveau un
parfum d'orient se répand à nancy le
football il dira à l'exotisme les
français jouent de plus en plus à
l'étranger
eh bien cette fois c'est un chinois qui
vient en france et on en a la preuve
vient pas du japon comme ça
la chine lachine lasalle lachine beachy
non lille chili les les les camps mais
ça va le cinéma indien dieu liste
présent ou non ces prénoms erreur celle
inverse lycée le nom gignoux c'est le
prénom à nancy pour l'instant il
s'installe il s'est évidemment où manger
et bien il lui reste maintenant
apprendre à vivre presque seul ce qu'à
21 ans il n'a jamais fait direction
alors toutes les adresses utiles et
nécessaires en l'occurrence un téléphone
et un fax qui seront les bienvenus un
ordinateur avec internet sera encore
mieux je suis originaire de shenyang
dans le nord-est de la chine
internet c'est vraiment bien pour ne pas
trop couper les ponts j'ai encore bien
sûr un peu le mal du pays mais mes
parents vont bientôt venir ici je suis
fier de jouer dans le pays vainqueur de
la coupe du monde je vais y faire
carrière et apprendre le français
la barrière de la langue c'est en effet
là la difficulté gignoux est forcément
seul dans son monde
le club le couvent donc comme un enfant
quelques mois après l'avoir repéré le
premier dans un tournoi espoir à toulon
on va parler de la van sande équipes de
chez savait très bien qu'on n'arriverait
jamais annoncée à faire venir le chinois
si douar là on l'a approché
débat il est là avec un entraîneur
d'origine roumaine des coéquipiers
portugais brésilien ou irlandais oui à
nancy on fuit dans le cosmopolite
en tout cas ligne ou avant peut-être ses
grands débuts face au psg est déjà le
joueur lorrain le plus célèbre cinéma
festival du film américain de deauville
projections de films du réalisateur
steven soderbergh dans le titre est hors
d'atteinte soderbergh c'est l'auteur de
sexe mensonges et vidéo qui fut pas le
mot d'or à cannes cette fois ci il a
choisi un style le policier sans
violence mais avec humour pour raconter
l'histoire d'un gentleman braqueur de
banques et de sa rencontre avec une
femme police dans quelques instants nous
retrouverons de george clooney à
deauville qui george clooney incarne ce
braqueur de banques mais avec eux nicole
cornu l'anglo fpjq de la rue voici
l'argument du film dans l'univers feutré
de deauville
c'est d'abord l'arrivée officielle dans
un palace puis l'hystérie collective
d'une séance de photos qui semble ravir
notre star et ce qui n'était qu'une
affiche devient soudain un événement
george clooney et jacques follet
gentleman désinvolte parmi les braqueurs
de banque
et pourtant malchance qu'il doit
retourner en prison on se doute bien que
george clooney le facétieux ne joue pas
un looser jacques follet n'est donc pas
un homme à rester enfermés ils ne
pensent qu'à se faire la belle mais la
belle c'est karen une détective qu'ils
arrêtent au cours de son évasion
et comme steven soderbergh le
réalisateur de sexe mensonges et vidéo
n'est pas homme à tourner une histoire
banale
le couple jack karen est explosif j'ai
compris tout de suite que dans la
société
la rencontre entre george et jennifer
était magique et correspondait
parfaitement au caractère des
personnages
elle laisse tomber ses armes et entre
rêve et réalité se crée entre une
relation obsessionnelle produit nommé
tacle c'est quand ils me rencontrent
différent de moi
il tombe amoureux de moi appelez ça
comme vous voulez je le trac pendant
tout le film
je suis un réel danger pour lui dans
cette passion se décident l'ours yoghi
c'est une course poursuite en tauride
rôle de gendarme et à drôle de voleurs
avec les clins d'oeil de george clooney
georges tournay bonsoir que doublé
bonsoir bonsoir voila c'était très
agréable vous entendre parler un petit
peu français
alors c'est un film out of sight c'est
un film d'action jeudi réussie c'est
peut-être un film sur le hasard l'idée
qu' on peut après tout dans la vie une
fois rencontré quelqu'un avec qui on a
théoriquement rien en commun c'est un
peu le comme ça vous parliez de ce film
en fait c'était une très bonne
description du tout ce qu'ils vont aller
voir le film je pense aurons une voiture
gratuite
est-ce que vous avez des rencontres
comme ça des rencontres à priori
impossible dans votre vie or votre vie
professionnelle
madan hilfiger l'intrus très sympathique
dans son restaurant à paris il ya
quelques années donc je suis j'en ai eu
fruits comment s'est passé le travail et
que ce verbe elle parce que c'était un
petit peu son premier polar il a fait
même un film sur kafka c'est plutôt un
réalisateur qui travaille dans un autre
genre comment vous allez travailler avec
lui et vous verrez bien c'était très
agréable de travailler avec lui c'est le
meilleur réalisateur que j'aie jamais
connue
c'est aussi d'ailleurs je pense le
meilleur scénario jusqu'à présent
j'espère que moi je n'étais pas
responsable de tous les erreurs qui ont
été commises en tout cas tout le reste à
bien marcher tous les autres comédiens
était parfait s'ils venaient en vérité
un auteur beaucoup de talent on vous dit
facétieux mais est ce que cela veut dire
que vous aimez bien vous amuser en
permanence y compris dans des sujets
plus graves plus sérieux vous avez
l'occasion d'interpréter un point dans
ma carrière où je ne veux pas je ne vais
pas ne pas vous amuser tout en
travaillant je ne sais pas chirurgien le
cerveau je suis interdite j'essaie de
m'amuser toujours quand je travaille
sinon pour moi il faudrait changer de
métier alors vous êtes en ce moment sur
france 2 sur la chaîne qui diffuse
régulièrement urgence
est-ce que urgence pour vous c'est une
chance un handicap un privilège comment
vous vivez cette célébrité mondiale due
au feuilleton urgence il ya urgence a
été c'est vraiment la raison toujours de
mon succès de ma réussite j'ai toujours
travaillé comme comédien mais cette
série a changé ma vie
donc pour moi ça n'a jamais été un
handicap un obstacle
ça a été une coup de chance vous n'avez
jamais eu peur du milieu médical vous
n'êtes pas hypocondriaque commandes et
je le trouvais des piqûres et je n'aime
pas l'impression avec tout ce matériel
médical autour de moi et on devient
forcément conduira qu'à force de
fréquenter cette série alors certains
artistes comédiens personnalités de la
culture américaine ont apporté leur
soutien à bill clinton
quelle est votre position sur ce qui se
passe en ce moment autour du président
des états unis a alors effectué vrai que
c'est vraiment dommage pitié que
l'existant maintenant possibilité de
craindre en prison qui était pas trop
mal
il pourra soit donné cette mention soit
il sera destitué et c'est vraiment
dommage car ça n'a que peu à voir avec
cette performance politique et plus avec
sa vie privée mais on verra
c'est dommage merci beaucoup george
clooney lèvres était avec nous en direct
ce soir de deauville pour ce festival du
film américain vous retrouvera sur
france 2 dans urgences merci des eaux
alors c'est aussi maintenant une star de
cinéma tout autre une vedette des fines
sauvez willy l'orc épaulard caïcos a été
rapatrié chez lui en islande dans le
fjord qui l'a vu naître ce cétacé de 21
ans qui pèse quelques cinq tonnes a fait
un voyage depuis newport etats-unis dans
une piscine spéciale keiko ça veut dire
leur garçon en islandais mais les
pêcheurs islandais eux ils résident
misait sur le willy business américain
et puis certains préfèrent winnie
l'ourson je vous rappelle maintenant la
fin de ce journal les quelques unes des
principales informations nous avons
développé dans cette édition
tout d'abord l'état de santé de monsieur
jean pierre chevènement qui s'est
améliorée il est sorti du coma dit un
communiqué nos états unis procureurs
chargés de l'affairé yves hinse qui a
remis son rapport aux membres du congrès
américain
et puis en russie nomination par boris
elstine de monsieur primakov comme
future commune
de russie investiture ruch assurer
demain comme monsieur le prix match dans
un instant la météo avec nathalie
rihouet puis envoyé spécial avec
notamment un reportage sur le viagra et
le marché des thérapeutiques destinés à
soigner les troubles sexuels en quête de
jacques merino le dernier journal c'est
à zéro heure 50 avec bruno roger-petit
demain dans les 4 vérités à 7h50
françoise laborde soit christian sautter
secrète avec l'eau du tchèque à 13h
carole gaessler rachid arhab et à 20h
retrouverez béatrice schönberg à lundi
bonsoir merci
dans quelques